we're also seeing uh Russia accuse  Ukraine of preparing to use a  radiological dirty bomb  this is absurd  allies rejects this blatantly false  accusation and Russia must not use false  pretext to escalate the war further  NATO not be intimidated or deterred from  support the Ukraine's right to  self-defense  for as long as it takes  President Putin's nuclear rhetoric is  dangerous and it is reckless and  irresponsible  any use of a nuclear weapon in Ukraine  will fundamentally change the nature of  the conflict  um President Putin Russia knows that a  nuclear war cannot be won and must never  be fought and I also know that there  will be severe consequences  so far we have not seen any changes in  Russia's nuclear posture but of course  we monitor very closely and we are  Christian and ready to act if necessary  but the most important thing now is  that they should of course not use a  nuclear weapon in Ukraine